you didn't hear Eric Griffin I'm kidding
it's my birthday oh that's true all
right how about this call me back call
me back I'll pop I'm gonna pick up again
yeah yeah just call me back call me
right back
I had you're right I shouldn't open that
way I was really bad see what he does
here we go you go
hey skinny anyway are you calling me for
happy birthday yeah okay thank you thank
you I love you thank you comeback on the
podcast okay come back all right I love
you so much so many people calling
though um good night I can't do far do
you keep hanging like I can't do phone I
honestly it's like you're doing great
this reminds me of how why I'm not good
at phone you know you're where'd you see
this - yeah this is that you don't
understand that Bilborough calling my
relationship with Bill and
I feel the same with Rogan is my
conversations with them are in and out
yeah hi a hug
how's the family good I'm out but do you
realize that it didn't take much for him
to call I understand I understand that
he doesn't it's not gonna take much I
mean I could still I consider him a
friend and I respect him and stuff like
that but I I just think that he's so
he's like to me like a Chappelle like
he's the top of the game and so for me I
can talk to a guy like Eric or
everyone's as funny and as talented but
he's just not you know his status isn't
there yeah he's your class of 92 right
where's Bill when he first moved to LA I
went to his house and I brought him a
gift like a DVD of Oldboy I don't know
why and I go watch this you know and I'm
it is at that time his girlfriend his
wife now um and I just get um I know
it's like when I see when you see Mitzi
all the time or if I see like if I'm on
Warner Brothers I see the president
Peter Roth he says hugs and he says hi
but I don't you to me it's like I can't
the longer in the conversation on end
though the more open I am the more you
think you're gonna say something you
shouldn't yes like it starts off first
five minutes like you're impressive and
then I it's not only a I'm gonna say
something and now I just thought of mmm
it's in every relationship the power you
can see there's power like with you and
me Gilbert we're friends but if there is
a power thing now you're my older right
oh I view it right so there's only so
much you can't really truly be yourself
in front of me because of the fact that
I'll slam you or you know I mean I know
I guess right you get so it's like in
everyone so I have that too I'm like
that like if I see Chappelle or Chris
Rock you know I'm like okay that
obviously did they have the power do I
like them they're nice Pete
but I because I always in a
conversations when you have somebody
with more power is they have you know
like the other net we're at
what's-her-name's party and if we talked
to Adam Carolla Adam Corolla had the
power in terms of shifting the
conversations to what he wants to talk
about what that's not a bad thing I'm
just saying that you know or if I'm
around a bunch of open mic errs it's
generally I'm telling the stories and
they're listening
[Music]